hello and welcome to this video with
radon AHA claims with III no Bishop c5
he says okay I don't really have any
knowledge about this liner to be honest
they all play this move but I have no
real idea I think mostly they take
nowadays and play Queen to e7 preventing
95 things I recently saw ladi force and
we're d4y our slow moves we go just
cancel we are now d5 1 how do you play
that I think it makes sense and my
development is pretty good and I might
win even more time under on the Queen
Queen doesn't have many great squares if
I call each form of where is he actually
placing this to e1 ok how to do this
yeah I can Bishop f5 this may be f3 it
looks make sense Amaya its move its most
active move
f 3 okay so I was thinking if there are
some tic-tacs and like night d40x night
F for those kind of things probably not
but it's it's close yeah this actually
threatens 94 then I'm not really yep
not really it was a honey it doesn't he
doesn't really care what any move I make
here takes Knight f4 it is kind of
dangerous think Snyder's
[Music]
94 takes Knight f4 what is what is he
doing then I'm threatening to take on g2
there and e2 is hanging you can play d3
ok
okey-dokey so what am i doing I probably
need more more pieces here if I want to
attack why maybe just this would be 8
rook t6 and so on here there are some
tactical things going on here like d3 he
also has to watch out for night sex on
III I've got some active pieces him and
that might say that's not that's all
good yeah only one my croc situation is
a little bit a little bit of
conservative concern here some but let's
say it's not an easy position for white
to play okay no I don't quite get it
where are you going with this ah to this
idea stepping stepping out of this okay
let that make sense
make sense okay bye take night takes its
rubbish so I have to move the Queen but
we never force also it's that's not all
oh all upside you know
[Music]
so how do I play the sand Bishop deform
trading that's not a bad thing to do but
also yeah I'm putting more pressure
there I just want to leave the night
maybe Knight f6 is a good simple move I
am it's something that I probably should
have anticipated
okay I did not anticipate maybe it's not
a big deal but
no it looks it looks fine
I think I don't see him trapping Michael
in here this I have not be sick so he
wants to go night at 4:00 okay
[Music]
and your time situation sucks the
position is good I think I can you just
take maybe will not sure about it but I
don't have cancel time to consider this
I mean I his King is we go and I have
night yeah okay that's possible of
course can just take everything off 95
will be very important point I think we
should define more a yes
[Music]
yeah I would like to play 95 of course
ah it's tough to figure out a candidate
set to go with go with it and hope it
works
you should be 42 yeah this one chick I
have no time could not tell him okay and
my background is killing me I am shoot
check here we should chicks I'm losing
this frigging game this is unbelievable
yeah
ah what a bad loss it replaces that was
a completely completely lost position
for white at one point and like here I
don't know I don't know I don't believe
in any of this sorry guys and that that
cannot be good really engine doesn't
agree okay what if we had came this is
sometimes so yeah maybe something here
was wrong Lionel okay so G takes wins
with remarkably this does not win yeah
yeah I was just lacking time we should
be success this probably doesn't work
should be one now that just doesn't work
I mean I'm down to 30 seconds I don't
know where boy did I squander way over
that time I don't really know
already here in the opening yeah I was
considering those those sacrificial
ideas yeah something like this but it
doesn't work you gt3 then what it was
okay I mean the position is is really
nice and I just screwed it up around
here
okay so just key takes okay I've got 95
coming in and everything and yeah here
the F file is simply closed this is a
big difference you cannot cover the tuna
this is a completely lost position 1953
and it was actually very simple okay
when you have to speed speed up but I
mean look at 6:00 it's amazing that this
is so much worse even this is not as
convincing I am probably get it too in
the other line yeah anyway thanks for
watching